Ven las noticias, consultan Internet,
y se toparon con esta imagen:
un niño, quizá menor de 10 años, limpiando un derrame de petróleo,
solo usando las manos,
en Sundarbans, la selva manglar más grande del mundo en Bangladesh.
Se quedaron muy sorprendidos
porque esta es el agua que beben, es el agua en la que se bañan,
el agua donde pescan, el lugar donde viven.
Pueden ver también que el agua es marrón,
el barro y el petróleo también son de color marrón
y cuando todo se mezcla, es muy difícil ver qué hay en el agua.
Pero existe una tecnología simple llamada espectrometría,
que permite que se vea lo que hay en el agua.
Construimos un primer prototipo de un espectrómetro
que puede alumbrar a través de toda clase de sustancias
que producen espectros diferentes,
lo que puede ayudar a identificar lo que hay en el agua.
Equipamos este prototipo con un sensor
y lo mandamos a Bangladesh.
Lo genial de este proyecto
es que más allá de resolver un problema local,
o de analizar un problema local,
mis alumnos usaron su empatía y su sentido de la creatividad
para ayudar de forma remota a otros niños.
[Puedo investigar un problema a distancia]
Me vi obligado a hacer un segundo experimento,
y quise ir un poco más lejos,
quizás abordar un problema más difícil, y también más cercano a mí.
Soy mitad japonés y mitad francés
y quizá recuerden, que en 2011, hubo un terremoto devastador en Japón.
Fue tan violento que desencadenó varias olas gigantes,
llamadas tsunamis,
y esos tsunamis destruyeron
varias ciudades en la costa este de Japón.
Más de 14 000 personas murieron en un instante.
También dañó la planta de energía nuclear de Fukushima,
una central nuclear cercana al agua.
Y hoy, según los informes
un promedio de 300 toneladas
aún se están filtrando de la planta nuclear en el océano Pacífico.
Hoy, todo el Océano Pacífico tiene trazas de contaminación por cesio-137.
Si vamos a la costa oeste,
podemos medir la radiación de Fukushima en todas partes.
Pero si nos fijamos en el mapa, parece que la mayor parte de la radiación
desapareció de la costa japonesa,
y la mayoría, de momento, tiene aspecto seguro, es azul.
Bueno, la realidad es un poco más complicada que eso.
He vuelto a Fukushima cada año desde el accidente
e investigo de manera independiente con otros científicos,
la tierra, el río,
y esta vez quisimos llevar a los niños.
Por supuesto no los llevamos, los padres no lo permitieron.
(Risas)
Pero cada noche informamos al centro de control...
aquí se ve el uso de máscaras diferentes.
Podría parecer que no tomaron el trabajo seriamente, pero sí lo hicieron
porque van a tener que vivir con la radioactividad toda su vida.
Junto con ellos
discutimos los datos recopilados ese día
y hablamos de lo que íbamos a hacer después,
las estrategias, el itinerario, etc.
Y para hacer esto, creamos un mapa topográfico rudimentario
de la región alrededor de la planta de energía nuclear.
Creamos el mapa de elevación,
introdujimos pigmentos para representar datos en tiempo real de la radiactividad,
y rociamos agua para simular la lluvia.
Con esto pudimos notar que el polvo radioactivo
se filtraba desde la cima de la montaña hacia el sistema ribereño
y desembocaba en el océano.
Era una estimación aproximada.
Pero con base en esto organizamos una expedición civil,
la más cercana a la central nuclear hasta la fecha.
Nos acercamos hasta 1,5 km de la central nuclear,
y con la ayuda de pescadores de la zona
fuimos recolectando sedimentos del lecho marino
con un rastreador de sedimento a medida que nosotros inventamos y construimos.
Colectamos el sedimento en bolsas pequeñas
y luego mandamos cientos de bolsas pequeñas
a diferentes universidades,
y elaboramos un mapa de la radioactividad del fondo marino,
especialmente en estuarios donde se reproducen los peces,
y espero que hayamos mejorado
la seguridad de los pescadores locales y de su sushi favorito.
(Risas)
Aquí vemos una progresión: hemos ido de un problema local
a un problema remoto, a un problema global.
y ha sido muy emocionante trabajar en estas escalas diferentes,
también con tecnologías de código abierto y muy simples.
Pero al mismo tiempo, ha sido cada vez más frustrante
porque solo hemos estado empezando a medir el daño que hemos hecho.
Ni siquiera hemos empezado a tratar de resolver los problemas.
Me pregunto si deberíamos dar el salto
y tratar de inventar mejores maneras de hacer todas estas cosas.
Así que el aula se volvió un tanto pequeña
por lo tanto, encontramos una instalación industrial en Hong Kong
y la convertimos en el espacio más grande
dedicado al impacto social y ambiental.
Está en el centro de Hong Kong
y es un lugar donde podemos trabajar con madera, metal,
química, un poco de biología, de óptica,
básicamente, se puede construir casi de todo allí.
También es un lugar donde los adultos y los niños pueden jugar juntos.
Es un lugar donde los sueños de los niños pueden volverse realidad
con la ayuda de adultos,
y donde los adultos pueden ser niños otra vez.
¡Estudiantes: aceleración! ¡Aceleración!
Cesar Harada: Preguntamos cosas como:
¿podemos inventar el futuro de la movilidad con energía renovable?
Por ejemplo.
O bien, ¿podemos ayudar en la movilidad de la población de edad avanzada
transformando sus sillas de ruedas estándar en nuevos vehículos eléctricos?
El plástico, el petróleo y la radioactividad
son legados terribles,
pero el peor legado que podemos dejar a nuestros niños son las mentiras.
Ya no podemos permitirnos proteger a los niños de la horrible verdad
porque necesitamos su imaginación para inventar las soluciones.
Así que, ciudadanos científicos, creadores, soñadores,
debemos preparar a la siguiente generación
para que se preocupe por el ambiente y la gente,
y para que realmente pueda hacer algo al respecto.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)